en el interior de este hospital cerca de
parís las pantallas de los ordenadores
se han apagado el sistema informático
del centro hospitalario de con juveniles
son está prácticamente paralizado
consecuencia de un ciberataque los
servicios no críticos han tenido que ser
dirigidos a otra parte este hombre que
está siendo tratado de un cáncer no ha
podido hacerse un escáner evitó el mouse
sabbath su hábito es que normalmente es
muy rápido porque está informatizado y
las pruebas y los escáneres se ven
directamente en el ordenador mientras
que ahora se ven obligados a trabajar a
mano aunque hola hizo villa de alhama
mucho ha tenido que empezar desde cero y
el personal ahora trabaja con recursos
limitados
en ríos ya que cada día tenemos que
volver a escribir la medicación de los
pacientes todas las recetas las
enfermeras ahora tienen que archivar los
manualmente en lugar de poner todos los
datos de los pacientes en el ordenador
tt con el hacker ha exigido un rescate
de 10 millones de dólares para
desbloquear el sistema pero el director
del hospital se rehúsa a efectuar el
pago porque el hospital no pagaría no ha
pagado y no pagará este tipo de rescate
la policía especializada en
ciberdelincuencia está llevando a cabo
una investigación
sobre el dinero de la piratería ha
superado al de la droga no se puede ver
lo que está en juego tenemos a las ciber
pandillas que recogerán la información
la pondrán a disposición y la venderán a
otros que ellos a su vez la re
utilizarán y revenderán a otros
un solo expediente médico puede venderse
hasta por 300 euros en el mercado negro
un valor más alto que el de los datos
bancarios los ciberataques dirigidos a
hospitales han aumentado últimamente
francia con 380 el año pasado lo que
supone un aumento del 70 por ciento
desde 2020